All right, let's cover a couple of other things
in the limited time we have left today, thanks
to that wacky and long interview with Mike
Pillow, my my pillow founder, Michael Dell,
we've been wondering, you know, sort of like
what is going to happen depending on what
does or doesn't happen in August or September.
Of course, there's going to be no reinstatement
of Donald Trump.
We are starting to get some data points that
they are planning something.
And I have one video to look at here with
you today.
This is an Amiga organizer named Matt Brainerd
affiliated with an organization called Look
Ahead America.
He was on with Steve Bannon and seems to be
saying that September 18th is going to be
a date on which they are going back to the
capital, of course, the capital being the
place where the Trump riots took place.
So let's listen to that.
Speaker 2: Actually going to make some news
on your show today.
We have our next rally planned in the middle
of September, September 18th.
And it's going to be huge.
And what's going to define it is where it's
going to take place.
Right?
We're going back to the capital.
Speaker 1: So understand.
Whether you consider this an overt or a more
sort of implicit signal about what they're
talking about, he's saying we're going to
redo January six.
Now, to what extent it's going to be redone,
we don't yet know
Speaker 2: right where it started on September
18th.
And we're going to push back against the phony
narrative that there was an insurrection.
We're going to provide the kind of evidence
that Nancy Pelosi won't allow to be presented
at her select committee showing that this
was a largely peaceful crowd, showing that
this was a crowd that was egged on in many
ways by Capitol Police throwing flash flash
bang grenades into a relatively peaceful crowd.
Speaker 1: Relatively peaceful is an interesting
way to describe it relative to what
Speaker 2: we're going to present the evidence
that actually Babbitts death should be investigated.
We're going to demand now.
Speaker 1: Now, remember, Ashleigh Babbitts
death was investigated.
It was investigated.
We have a full report about it.
Speaker 2: At least 14000 hours of videotape
that the federal government has been suppressing.
Speaker 1: That's another one of these where
we we have even if you grant that not every
minute of video has been released, we already
have hours and hours and hours and hours and
hours of video.
And so the idea that only the video that's
being kept secret, as they claim, is what
would change our entire perception of what
took place.
That's another false narrative that they're
pushing.
Speaker 2: So we're going right back to the
Capitol because we're not afraid and we're
going to press our case.
And I believe that we're going to have some
very high profile speakers there.
We're going to have members of Congress speak.
We're going to continue to raise the volume
and push back against this phony narrative
and demand justice for these political prisoners,
Speaker 1: justice for political prisoners.
Can you imagine?
So if you check out the website for this organization,
Lookahead America, they said they've announced
their next rally.
It's called Justice for J. Six, if you can
imagine something more depraved.
And they say it will be at the Capitol on
September 18th at noon.
So much reason to be worried.
And hopefully this is something that law enforcement
is paying attention to.
We'll talk about that a little bit more tomorrow